so confidence in the very purest sense
comes from i am
i'm here i'm alive i'm breathing i'm a
drop of consciousness i'm spirit
individualized whatever word you want to
use you know the universe whatever but i
am here i am present i am alive and that
is where the real confidence comes from
so the more we anchor into that
like i was saying with my example of you
know i was doing these practices and
then there just started to be this flow
um we start to understand that really
life um transforms like we transform our
lives from the inside out
so a lot of us engage in this arduous
pushing externally the ego is like
wanting to say oh you need to do more
you need to get more even the way we
approach love we think we need to get
love from other people we need to get
this and this and that's the ego um
playing out lack
this podcast exists because i love
talking to people and i love going deep
the purpose is to plant seeds of
inspiration we enter a space of
vulnerability and relatability and what
you realize is that we are so much more
alike than we are different to quote
ramdas we're all just walking each other
home and this show is just one step i'm
danica patrick and i'm pretty intense
today on the podcast is kimberly snyder
the lovely kimberly she is a good friend
kimberly is a spiritual teacher a
teacher of meditation she's a
nutritionalist holistic wellness expert
three-time new york times best-selling
author she has six books her latest one
being called you are more than you think
you are which is what our topic of
conversation was super good book i mean
it's it's really just the one of the
words in the title uh and on the cover
is practical and that's just the perfect
word for it because it really hits on a
lot of topics in in a really uh clear
and concise way we talked about letting
go we talked about fear we talked about
love we talked about forgiveness purpose
and of course the most important thing
which is your true self you know i love
that she describes the true self as the
center and at the center of everything
is where everything is the most peaceful
and calm and so uh it was just a really
clear concise just like her book
conversation so i think you're going to
fall in love with her i think you're
going to want this book and i think
you're probably going to want to buy it
for some friends so enjoy the episode
today with the wonderful kimberly snyder
how's it going how how are you oh it's
so good i'm so glad we could have this
time together i feel like you know we we
text sometimes we're in the same city
sometimes we're not but i always love of
course catching up with you so thank you
for having me back on like to jump right
into the book because obviously that's
what i want to talk to you about uh
first off congrats it's always such
a big deal to write a book i have to
tell you a funny story about this one
which was um first of all it kind it
just came down when i was 34 weeks
pregnant with my younger son who you met
and i it was at a time when i was trying
to slow down and not necessarily write a
book but we can't always control the
timing it really just came in and it was
so strong and so i reached out to deepak
chopra who i wrote a book with two books
ago and i said deepak i have this idea
and i told him and he said oh this book
belongs with hay house which was a
different publisher than my previous two
so he puts me on an email with reid
tracy the president and he's like well
kimberly what's your book about and so i
told him
and i think a week later i presented it
on zoom i wrote one sample chapter and
it was three days before i gave birth
that i wrote um that i signed my book
deal and then 60 days after writing or
after giving birth i started writing and
oh my gosh danica this first of all i
look at it i'm like oh my god how did i
write this it was during covid my older
son who's four was not in preschool that
i had a newborn and this book it just
felt like
it doesn't feel like my book it feels
like it wants to be here
you know like the the teachings and
what's in it and i feel like i'm in
service to the book and i haven't had
that experience with the previous five
books
wow well i remember being at your house
yes um which was so beautiful so
relaxing in nature
and
you were talking about you had started
writing a book that was i feel like you
had talked about that point either that
or maybe the
maybe the i was editing it i think yes
was it um moses was here right
yeah or did i i think maybe i met you
when i was still pregnant but then i
can't remember my brain
no moses was here because you were i yes
i don't know for sure you m maybe you
were but i just remember you talking
about
this is the most important book this
one's different this one feels really
special and
you know
maybe just explain why that is you know
having five previous books already you
know what was it about this one that
felt so different or you know other than
of course the the way that it came
through at a time where you were like
i'm ready to slow down and they're like
no no no no
we got other plans for you more books
i feel like
with other books danica it's covered
different aspects of lifestyle so um
actually can i tell you another quick
story about this how this came to be so
actually um in the book i talked about
this in the beginning how i didn't
really know what i was going to do with
my life
and i went into college thinking i might
be a doctor i had a partial science and
math scholarship but then i interned in
a hospital one summer and realized it
wasn't my path but i ended up working
for a year and saving up some money
and then i decided to travel for a few
weeks
and i think you know looking back i was
i was seeking and i didn't know exactly
what i was seeking but i was trying to
find some relief
from the discomfort i had within myself
i had a lot of anxiety a lot of insomnia
a lot of digestive issues acne a lot of
self-doubt um you know i had just been
recovering from eating disorders so i
was just sort of like angst and so i
went out on the road
and i didn't realize how inexpensively i
could travel so i was doing it for a
couple dollars a day in some countries i
was in southeast asia the rest of asia
for 18 months and then africa where i
bought a car and i was living out of the
car but the reason i tell you this is
because one of the most impactful
countries for me was india and the first
time i went i was there for three months
and then i went back circled around and
i was there for another longer period so
when i was in india danica it was the
first time i really started learning
about yoga and meditation and so i
didn't really know the difference until
i came back to the west a lot of people
think yoga is just the poses but it's
not it's really this whole system for
creating union within our you know
between the ego and this um the true
self which we'll get into in a moment
this unlimited part of us so anyways i i
didn't know much but i was starting to
read these books and particularly from
paramahansa yogananda it was this great
yoga guru that brought yoga to the west
and so i was starting to really go into
these practices and then i got back from
traveling and i ended up in new york you
and i were just talking about this
because my family's from the east coast
and oh my gosh i was i was broke and i
didn't have any money um but i scraped
together a little bit to sublet a place
and then i was um teaching yoga
and asanas and then i was going back to
nutrition school and then all i did was
start a free wordpress blog and the only
people i told were my yoga students
because i didn't know anything about
marketing or seo and then the funny
thing is it started spreading
organically through new york city and
people started
hearing about it and then my first
celebrity found me and so i started
working with her i got on the film set
and i started working with other actors
then i got pulled into that world and
the funny thing is i still don't own a
tv so i certainly wasn't trying to get
into that world but it was starting to
you know add more um you know wings to
my platform and then i started going on
these national television shows like gma
and all this stuff was unfolding so
here's the funny part about the story
the first book deal came and it was with
harpercollins and that my editor was
sarah and i said oh i have an idea for a
book and i had this manuscript i put
together and it was called catching the
fire and it was a travel memoir
with a lot of these teachings that are
in this book
and she looked at it and she goes okay
then she looked at my website and she's
like well the food and the recipe part
seems to be taking off so why don't we
do a food book first and then we'll do
this book second
well that was exactly to this year 10
years ago
and so that the first book was the
beauty detox solution that you know just
took off sold like a million copies so
then the second book they wanted to do a
food book then the third book started
coming back it was about chakras it was
called beauty detox power um then the
fourth book i wrote with deepak which
was aryuveda and spirituality then the
fifth book was a hybrid but this book
danica the reason i'm so passionate
about it this is the first time i'm
sharing my full playbook
of these teachings that are you know
buried in thousands of pages of ancient
text and really showing how useful and
helpful they are today in helping us to
alleviate suffering get past fear live
our best lives really step into our
creative power and our confidence which
i believe is possible for anybody and
their support of science and stories to
show their relevance yeah
which is great and there's there's like
calls to action yes when you say
playbook as i'm reading it i'm like it
totally is because you hit on so many
different topics and sometimes i read a
book about spirituality or
um
you know some sort of facet of wellness
and yeah you know you could have
probably taken this book and made five
different books out of it you know you
could have a book that just has to do
more with meditation and connection with
your body and then you could have done
another one that has to do with like
you know um you know the relationship
with the outside world and things that
you could have probably broken this down
into so many different books but you
didn't and you really kept it concise
which i love and then i also love that
at the end of the chapters that there's
there's ways to to to go deeper into
what it is that you're talking about
with prompts and questions and and and
ways to guide people through certain
steps whether it be
breathing or meditation or just how to
sit even during your meditation
um and and i just think that that's so
great because it's it's like one of
those things you know it's like going to
a wellness conference and you leave
feeling like so buzzed and energized and
excited and then you know a couple days
later you're kind of like back to normal
because nothing's changed and so
i love that there's ways that people can
go deeper and that you encourage them
from the very beginning in the book
where you say get a journal out and get
ready to start writing because that's
such a huge part of it and i've found
that with my own practice is that the
more that i say things out loud the more
that i write them down the more that i
get these really
gems of prompts make you just open up
like a flower and sometimes there's rain
water in the flower in the form of tears
but
so beautiful so so so beautiful
well thank you love and
it's true that the subtitle of the book
is practical enlightenment for everyday
life and so it was so important to me
that the book was is practical because
to your point sometimes i read i love
eckhart tolle i read his stuff and then
i'm like this sounds really great i'm
i'm bored with the philosophy but how do
i really live this right so every
chapter like you said whether it's going
into confidence there's a 90-second
reset if you start to find yourself in
comparison mode or triggered or whatever
it is to come back same thing with
abundance and so on and so forth um so
the book is structured in three parts
the first is getting past the biggest
blocks because if we don't get past the
biggest blocks including fear um hold
the wholeness chapter is seeing that we
are beyond our behaviors then we can't
really get on the path in the first
place and so the word enlightenment is
about freedom it's about more awareness
it doesn't mean we're going to be fully
enlightened like jesus or buddha but
just getting on the path and having
practices
starts to shift our energy little by
little every single day and so the
meditations i teach the practical
enlightenment meditations are usually
like seven minutes right so i'm not
asking people to do a complete overhaul
of their life if the titanic was turned
one degree from the beginning of the
journey history would have been changed
and then the second part of the book is
embodying more of the qualities of the
true self
like confidence
um intuition piece and then the third
part danica is really um exciting we
don't want to skip ahead to that but the
longest chapter in the book is called
you are a creator and it's about once
we've established part one and two it's
how do we work with our unique energy
and our unique gifts which are formless
they're energetic and how do we extract
that and put it through these exercises
into actual form into creating our best
product or idea or
website or whatever it is so there's a
very practical nature to this um and
what you mentioned before about
journaling um there's eight limbs of
yoga you know back to this core concept
that yoga is really about union and the
the essential message of this book is
how do you connect to this often dormant
part of you that's called the true self
that is the goal of yoga and within the
niyamas which are the second limb of
yoga there's something called sparia
which is introspection and self-study so
yoga is laid out for thousands of years
this whole process of introspection
that's why the journaling prompts are
really important not just reading these
teachings or this information but seeing
huh what are my patterns how does this
apply to me what are my wounds or my
triggers or ways that i act out of the
ego versus the true self
energy
so it keeps um again it's it's relevant
and it's practical and um it is possible
i believe to create great change in your
life with these teachings i love wayne
dyer calls ego edging god out
as an acronym and it's so true so let's
talk about the true self because that's
something like
you know at the core like you said the
true self um the what you're trying to
get to and i love also in the book how
you talk about like that true self like
the center of everything is
always which is such a beautiful
visualization of it um but maybe it's
starting with the question of because
there's going to be a lot of people like
including what is the true self yeah
exactly like it's hard to know like even
if we just know who we to know who we
really are is a challenge and like it's
a journey and i don't know if i'll ever
be off of that ever ever finish that
journey the the um hopefully i get to
the point where i feel much more wrapped
up my hands wrapped around the truth and
through nature and the true self um
and i've come a long way but like why is
it that people have such a hard time
just even getting to the point where
they know who they are when i was like
married a hundred years ago
like there used to be a lot of drinking
and then the next relationship there was
none
and like even in this environment any
example of like all this way all that
way i went i don't know who i am
and like it took me years to really
figure out even where i was in the ebb
and flow of something just like that
you know which is something probably
practical that a lot of people
participate in on a regular basis and
it's like so when i say who you really
are it's like who are you minus
everything else why is that so hard
great so there's like a million things i
want to say about this i love this
question danika so first of all um the
the
the issue the biggest issue i see today
hands down across
everything the reason people i believe
suffer so much the reason there's so
much comparison feeling not enough
feeling not good enough all of these um
like
these forms of suffering come from one
root cause which is that we over
identify with the ego the pseudo soul so
what wayne dyer calls the less than two
percent of who we are so what is the ego
the ego is this part of us that's
sensing with the five senses so it's
what we see with our physical eyes
including looking in the mirror what we
look like what other people are doing on
social media it's always looking out
touching hearing what's out here
right so there's we are having an
embodied experience we are here in a
physical body so of course we are going
to have an ego to an extent we need to
be in the world but the issue is when we
put our full identity and our self-worth
in this
right so the true self what yoga teaches
us is this formless part of us
so it's not something we can see with
our physical eyes necessarily it's
beyond what we look like and it's also
beyond what we do so i want to get to
behavior in a moment
so
this part of us is it's the voice of the
the heart of the intuition it's this
part of us that's beyond thought like
eckhart used to always say beyond
thought i didn't really know what he was
talking about but we tune into this
stable um resource inside of us this
courageous infinitely creative um
intelligence inside of us when we learn
we've got to get to know it so first of
all we need to spend time out in the
world and balance that with inner
connection meditation stillness being in
nature because otherwise like you said
we get very confused and we start to
identify who we are without here so
anytime you you're saying to yourself
hmm
i don't feel good enough you see
something that triggers you like someone
walks by and you're like oh i should be
i should be 10 pounds lighter or
whatever or something happens or you
know whatever you see a social media
post and you think whatever it is
it's important that first of all in that
moment you pause and that feeling comes
up you start to recognize it and you say
oh
i'm identifying with my ego in this
moment
right that is what all of that is
because when we are connected to the
true self we understand that we are this
unique creation of spirit and no one can
be us and no one um we can't be anyone
else so in the confidence chapter
i talk about the difference between
surface confidence and true confidence
surface confidence is in the ego so it's
like i'm you know
i've got really great skin or like look
at my achievements so for me used to be
like look at my straight a's it was all
like my worth was in my grades always my
perfectionism but the problem is out
here is the swirl of dynamic change all
the time so if we pin our confidence to
anything out here it's always going to
go up and down so the true source of
confidence yoga teaches us and when you
peel away the layers and the layers and
you keep going deeper and deeper is one
thing danica it's very simple
as when you know the statement when when
moses asked the almighty um you know
what is this what are you and it was one
statement i am that i am right so
confidence in the very purest sense
comes from i am
i'm here i'm alive i'm breathing i'm a
drop of consciousness i'm spirit
individualized whatever word you want to
use you know the universe whatever but i
am here i am present i am alive and that
is where the real confidence comes from
so the more we anchor into that
like i was saying with my example of you
know i was doing these practices and
then there just started to be this flow
um we start to understand that really
life um transforms like we transform our
lives from the inside out so a lot of us
engage in this arduous pushing
externally the ego is like wanting to
say oh you need to do more you need to
get more even the way we approach love
we think we need to get love from other
people we need to get this and this and
that's the ego um playing out lack
and the opposite is when we realize that
we are in charge of our we can what we
can work with is our inner state
yeah and it's this frequency inside of
us abundance is really showing when the
fullness of this moment so we're we're
here and we're present we're breathing
and we're not lacking anything we're not
comparing ourselves we're not an ego
identification we are in connection with
this essence inside of us and then that
repeated frequency over time starts to
attract and create people are drawn to
you people say oh what are you what is
this what are you working on they want
to you know opportunities come and more
relationships things get deeper um and
deeper and so it's this beautiful
unfolding danica of your entire life
which is why i'm so passionate about
this book is because i've seen in my own
life and i talk about in the book some
really hard times i've been through and
some really you know um
uh challenging to say at least uh
personal relationships and things that i
have
transcended to now live you know and i
got deeper and deeper into this after my
you know rock bottom place about four
years ago and now i'm like oh my gosh it
doesn't have to be as arduous and
pushing and living from the ego as we've
been led to believe there's this whole
other way of living yeah yeah and i
would love to talk about that that that
sort of
transition that happened um but
to just go back to the the true self
and what i'm hearing is it's like
essentially
it's it's you minus the thinking mind
so it's like feeling being my like
gravitating towards the things that you
want to do it's like isn't it magical
how when you finally get good and happy
with yourself and you start serving
yourself showing up for yourself doing
the things that light you up and like
you just sort of
all the sudden doors start opening and
it's like to me it's because you get the
thinking mind out of the way you're
feeling what you're feeling and you're
and you're moving towards those things
and it's not your thinking mind coming
in going oh maybe that's a waste of time
that's stupid that's not you know you
yeah that's not gonna make you look
better that's you know it's like get the
thinking mind out of the way and it's
like more about the feeling and then in
that space you can also come to these
more
um
pillar moments of like a certain knowing
that comes into your existence and being
that i think that if we all slowed down
enough to
think about we all
probably can remember those times where
it was like you know could be about a
job a person a relationship any kinds of
things and you're like i kind of knew
it's like you have a knowing inside of
you that you can't
really it's harder to listen to when you
have the thinking mind in the way yes so
the thinking mind and the overthinking
mind and what zen buddhists call the
monkey mind is the um the the ego really
playing out and whispering in your head
all the time and keeping you and self
down keeping you kind of over evaluating
all the time so
when you talked about feelings and
emotions um
energy and motion is really what
emotions are too and so there's there's
more activity in that so what we're
talking about with the true self and
this is where this is where the
practices come where we hone in and we
hone in um one of the limbs of yoga is
called pratyahara and first you know
when i read this you know when i started
off like 12 years ago i was like ah that
sounds good but this was the game
changer for me danica pratyahara means
withdrawing the senses inward so what
does that mean it means
the the ego is always tuned out here and
out here right
so meditation isn't just i'm going to
relax because basically is like i'm
relaxing my five senses no no we want to
do practices that actually bring us from
the peripheral nervous system into the
central nervous system which is known as
the sushumna nadi it's our main energy
channel and there is science to this
right so we know when we're in our spine
and the yogi's um in uh i forget which
chapters i think it's chapter 11. i talk
about focusing on your third eye what
this literally does is it activates this
little notch this part of your brain
back here where the notch is called your
medulla oblongata so when you're
activating here this ganglion of nerves
you are literally lighting up different
parts of your brain like your creative
center and the parts of you that are
more and less emotional and more into
equanimity right so
these practices are very specific
they've been around for thousands of
years it's not just oh relax
um and creating stillness is important
but that's why this book is so specific
with these practices because we want to
have downtime but we also want to use we
want to learn how to direct our energy
in specific ways you know yogananda
talked about the underlying energy
matrix of all things so he was very
specific um which he knows
jesus and krishna and all the there's a
court of all religions at the lake
shrine temple here because he was saying
what i'm talking about you can be any
religion or you can be no religion we're
talking about energy we're talking about
um you know in quantum physics it's
gravitational field where it's not
separate particles but it's you know
waves everything is interconnected so
when you're working to yoke or create
union with your you know our limited
smallness which is when we think we're
an eco and instead we unite through the
spine through our central channel and
our brain into you know universal
creative intelligence source god
whatever word you want to use now you're
tapping into unlimited creativity and
your best ideas that are being funneled
through your um again your individual
consciousness it just it expands and
expands
um so i guess you know it sounds a
little esoteric so maybe i'll give i'll
give an example is you know when you
mentioned um you know just tuning in
more going past the thinking mind
when i went through my rock bottom
period it was you know i was a new mom
my son wasn't my older son wasn't yet a
year and then i lost my mom really
suddenly she you know from her cancer
diagnosis to when she passed it was less
than six weeks
and then i kind of had this moment you
and i have talked about this where i was
like ugh like this is not the life i
want you know this guy i was with he was
a great guy by the way i would never say
anything badly about him but we just
weren't this like deep emotional we
didn't have this deep emotional
connection so then i moved out on my own
so then i was new mom lost my mom became
a single mom
and this monk that i met with at the
self-realization fellowship
his advice which is yogananda's
meditation organization his advice was
treat your home like an ashram for five
months this is before kovic so i took
care of my child i worked and the rest
of the time danica i was reading
scripture so i was reading the vedas the
upanishads the mahabharata the bhagavad
gita the new testament of the bible rumi
like all these old teachings and i was
meditating and i was just just going
deep and deep
and what happened after that period you
know after more than five months i
emerged with this deeper sense of
trust like trusting myself like the true
self trusting life just um just more
resilience and more strength and more
power
how how could you trust yourself more
so through this period um i think you
know again through deep introspection
and stillness and doing these practices
came to realize how much i give my power
i was giving my power away and i think
most of us do this in terms of like oh
this is my idea what do you what do you
think of it right or like again trying
to get the love or the validation like
compliments or people agreeing with you
or all this stuff out here versus one of
the biggest benefits of this work i've
found is when you start to really
connect to the stable place inside of
you you realize you don't need that much
from the outside we are autonomous this
love that we're seeking from out here we
can give it to ourselves we can validate
ourselves we find the peace inside right
we connect here and most of our needs
are met the reason there's so much drama
in relationships and issues is because
we are transferring us
our needs no instead of through here
we're trying to get something from other
people so so the story goes so then so
then okay so that was five months i was
in there and then i emerged and here's
the funny part of the story you've met
my husband danica so then i was at this
dinner party
months later
and i was here right i mean like i was
in my heart and i was in my gut and i
was feeling whole so i was complete i
was good i was just walking around like
not trying to get anything
and then boom i met john future hubby
who again if i'd been here like you were
saying danica in the mind i wouldn't
walk right by him because i'm like this
guy's not my type you know completely
covered in tattoos gold grill
um plant-based he's a huge meat smoker
he told me it's the first conversation
you know motorcycles mma fighting but it
was it was not a logical rational you
know evaluation it was this attunement
to energy and i was just like wow i feel
this connection
and then you know he felt it too even
though he said he would never get
married he said within 15 minutes he
felt like i was going to be his wife wow
and so um you know i'll say that the
practical nature of this i look back to
anakin and i'm like oh [ __ ] like if i
hadn't done that i think my soul mate
would have gone by me and i wonder how
much how many times you know that
happens before two up here in the ego it
blocks right instead of this flow of the
heart and living from the true self
right
right it's like this different way of
living and the other thing you said
before was like i do this or i do this i
drink or i don't
um in the chapter i am whole
this is a really interesting chapter
because i think one of the things that
holds us back so much is we become
attached to our behaviors and the yogis
teach us until we are yoked truly to the
true self as humans our behavior is
always going to be unpredictable and
unreliable so what we want to do is we
want to have that you know pull the
shadows out look at the so-called good
and bad and then take the lessons clean
up the mess apologize if we need to but
then let it go so that we're not holding
on to guilt and shame yeah
you know another big another big topic
in the book was about forgiveness too
and you know i think this is such a
pertinent one because i think the one
that can almost probably bring well me
but maybe maybe anyone listening is just
not only forgiving others but maybe most
importantly yourself because the way you
treat yourself is the way you treat
others so if you can't forgive yourself
how can you really forgive anyone else
and like what haven't we all done so
many things in your in our life where
we're like man i need to forgive myself
for
xyz
abc def like all the different things
that happen and it's like you know maybe
that's something good to talk about is
just yes forgiveness and the role that
it plays and why it's such an important
part of moving forward
so where where our power is and where we
can bring the most love light support
into the planet is right here in this
moment right so what i was saying about
behavior we've all done [ __ ] we've all
done stuff that we wouldn't do again
that we may regret whatever it is but we
cannot take it back
so in the whole chapter there's a
practice and i'll simplify it here but
it's where you list your sun qualities
which are the ones we like to you know
we like to share i'm
patient i'm a good friend
i remember everybody's birthdays like
whatever it is i you know i i'm generous
whatever it is we list it pretty easy to
rattle off right and then we and i
recommend doing this after we meditate
so we have a chance to just be more
rooted and grounded and then we start to
write our lunar qualities which are the
parts of us that we don't necessarily
like to share with the world
but as we we continue to go back to this
practice it goes deeper and deeper so oh
you know i actually can be judgmental or
i can be mean or i can be exclusive or i
can be snobby or whatever it is and then
we list them and then what happens when
you list those danica is you will start
to feel the reactions of the ego in
terms of sensations in your body your
body will reflect um your reaction so
what does that mean you may start to
feel your heart racing or you may start
to feel for me it feels like
constriction so a constriction in my my
belly or in my heart
so what that means is we still have
attached energy to those parts of us
that we haven't metabolized or we
haven't processed we sort of pushed away
into the shadow right carl jung talks
about bringing things in out into the
light so it actually starts to melt the
darkness just by nature of starting to
see things so in this practice we want
to hold the sun qualities and the moon
qualities up equally and look at them
like like a you know yin yang like both
of these are part of me and we let the
sensations rise and fall which is
helping us to metabolize the shame and
the guilt and then we realized then the
next practice after that is going beyond
that and realizing the surface all these
behaviors danica it's still the ego like
acting out of its wounds and underneath
that is the stability of the true self
that is beyond behavior now as we get
really anchored in of course our actions
and our words are an extension of our
true self but right now we're you know
we're having a human experience so the
duality is that we're becoming as humans
we're still evolving and becoming and
there's the true self part of us that is
already whole and complete so there's a
little bit of this duality this play so
what it means is we forgive ourselves
for being human we don't trample down on
that humanness we don't beat ourselves
up forever because we can't take it back
we learn the lessons we continue to
evolve and we continue to align more to
the true self
yeah i love that practice of being able
to look at the sun and yes
and look at those qualities and
identifying starting to almost basically
like give your
familiarize yourself with what it feels
like to be
uh
in love to to have your heart opening to
be
joyful and then to feel what it feels
like in your body because this the body
ends up becoming like the barometer for
things yes and i'm sure that that's
plays a huge role in your life like you
know how does the body feel when a
situation comes up someone something any
anything the body is the indicator it's
not like it's not you don't always get
some there's just a booming voice from
above going like this is a bad decision
i mean you might hear some sort like i
call them like knowings like you know
something just hits you in a couple of
words but a lot of times it's a it's a
body that it's the it's the physical
sensation first but then on the other
side when you can feel the contraction
and then you can start to identify the
more you practice that um back and forth
and knowing what that's like to go out
into the real world and have things
happen and be like oh wow i'm feeling
that this must mean something something
is like i should be cautious right now
um i think is such a valuable practice
for somebody what would they do so
what's the practice then with the you
know the the moon the lunar side of your
your your personality and um
what you do with those is there
something you're supposed to actually do
other than just witness them
to
balance them or dissolve them or or or
create some sort of alchemy with them
yeah so that this is the whole chapter
which again is in part one which is
about getting past the biggest blocks so
there's a you know that's similar but
there is a extended practice in the fear
chapter which is actually the first one
um fearlessness which yo bananda says if
we um 26 soul qualities that a human
needs to develop in order to reach their
fullest potential um fearlessness is
number one because if we're riddled with
fear we don't even want to see we don't
even want to get on the path in the
first place so what we want to do is we
want to just start to see and witness in
these practices so we're sort of like
pulling things out of the dark corners
and we're starting to look right so the
word um enlightenment again means
freedom we can never be free if we are
controlled by we get hijacked or we act
all these patterns we don't even know
what's going on we just think to
ourselves we project we blame we're like
oh that person's an [ __ ] all right i
just don't like them or whatever it is
it's like always out here versus shining
the mirror inside and seeing oh you know
my true nature is bliss and
unconditional love and what are the
things that have happened that create
distortions and that like why do i act
out in these ways or why does this
really bother me so for me danica oh my
gosh when i started doing this work
i used to think okay i like to move
things along the most um
one of the things that bothered me the
most was when people interrupted me
right
or i would go into this you know
explanation let's say oh phil should
need a lot of dairy and then they
wouldn't agree with me so part of me was
like oh you know it's just annoying i
would just like toss it off as this
person's annoying but i started to
really sit with this okay so
it gets deeper to answer your question
we build and build we start to see
what's there and then we start to
dissolve it in different ways and
different practices of bringing in more
light because these different these
lunar aspects are you know darkness and
what is darkness darkness is an absence
of light darkness is not necessarily
evil we don't want to create shame and
you know weigh ourselves down it's just
that we need to nourish these aspects of
us so for me i could see oh you get
really impatient when people interrupt
you when they don't agree with you what
is that so then i would sit with it and
through this work through these
practices i could see oh the reason it
bothers me so much is because it's
triggering some very primal um fear in
me that i'm not good enough to be seen
or heard
and underneath that was like i'm not if
i'm not good enough to be seen and hurt
it's because i'm not lovable right like
a deep deep deep primal wounds you know
things that happened in my childhood
and so once i saw that as the root the
behavior was an extension but the root
wound which again we take you
sequentially into healing this
was this oh i don't feel lovable and
once i saw that danica then i started to
tune into the ways in which we give
ourselves love
no more like dancing around or all the
ways in which i was giving my power away
trying to get the love and reinforce
myself and validate myself which is
really validating the ego anything from
outside instead it was like well i can
show up for myself i can give myself the
love i can again self-soothe validate
and the healing that came from that was
so tremendous because what happens then
danica and this is what this is what
cures a lot of relationship issues is we
then become whole as individuals so when
we're with our partner we're with
someone else a friend we're not trying
to get anything from them right we're
not trying to get them to agree with us
we're not trying to get them to see our
exact perspective we're just sharing
life and oh my god danica am i telling
my in-laws game last week who are very
intense and they've bothered me a lot in
the past and this is just how much the
work continues i was just there and i
got to tell you honestly from my heart
they didn't bother me at all all the
ways in which they'd like say things and
visited like my god they don't get it at
all
it hard to get to that point where you
actually can see it in real life real
time
different
good it adds up top these practices
danny i'm saying you just like seven
minutes of meditation then you do a
check-in during the day which could be
90 seconds one of my practices or five
minutes and the end of the day you think
oh what's that going to do but really if
you're turning the energy inward which
is always going out and the realizations
may come it's non-linear so you don't
realize how much it starts to add up and
accrue and build into this more
expansive way of looking at things in
this much more grounded place where we
are because trying to get stuff from
people all the time and you know all the
ways in which we really are trying to
get things it's part of our primal fear
attached to our identity it's an
exhausting way to live life and it's
arduous and it actually blocks abundance
it blocks love it blocks a lot of things
from coming in because this desperate
energy is really an energy of lack and
it actually repels things from us
you said that
fear
is actually
you
feeling
like you're lacking something right
isn't that what you say that fear is do
you think you're missing something yeah
fear is being an ego because if i'm an
ego i'm scared that oh my god i'm
getting older my body's gonna break down
all this stuff's gonna happen to me and
you know someone's gonna outdo my stuff
my project at work i'm not gonna get the
promotion it's because we're still here
all the time it doesn't mean we need to
we're gonna take steps we're gonna work
on our skills we're gonna be in the
world but when we tune into the true
self this eternal part of us we don't
have the same
fears that are taking over life every
day you know one of my other favorite
chapters danica is the warrior chapter
right and this um sanskrit word is uh
kostria this warrior part of us
you know in yogananda's commentary he
says something throw yourself into the
din of battle and do not worry about
results so this means when we're living
from our heart when we are taking right
action dharma so we've concentrated our
energy and then we see where we want to
put it we go for it we create we're not
riddled with fear of what if this
doesn't work out what if you know they
don't like me
and that was also a big difference in
writing this book danica i think you
know as an author and you know this too
the publisher wants to have input like
oh this is what's trending this is
what's going on out here products
whatever it is and so it's almost this
reverse engineering of here's what's out
here and here's how we reflect that
with this it was none of that outside it
was like boom this is inside of me and i
feel like i feel so passionate about
this and so it's it's unfolding from the
inside out like i think this is how our
best stuff is created whoever we happen
to be is we're we're um birthing
something truly it's so connected so
deep within us and then it comes out of
our unique talent and our unique energy
um and i think when we over evaluate
again the ego just trying to figure out
from here and then do it the other way
that's when you know things don't always
work out so well
what are some practices that you've
noticed over time
that help get you into that state of
more of a clear channel more
present more connected to the true self
and the message that you have and then
what have you noticed over time or some
of the things that you do that take you
out of that or make it feel a lot maybe
more blurry and a little less clear and
a little less a little less um
obvious what you're what you should be
doing next or saying next or even yes
yeah just doing sometimes is even the
way it's like i don't know what should i
do now so i kee i keep saying this word
danica practices because i think that's
the most important thing here right it's
like otherwise we're just a leaf blowing
in the wind like once in a while i do a
yoga retreat and i feel good or i see a
happy instagram post and i'm like yeah
but
practices that really are what is how we
are working with energy so for instance
in the morning routine i teach hot water
with lemon great good for your digestion
get the vitamin c in get the hot water
in which helps you feel stabilized in
your physical body take your spo
probiotics do something for your gut
health and then always always it's
sitting to meditate even if it's seven
minutes in the practical enlightenment
meditations that i teach because from
the beginning of the day we want to be
creating a pattern of flow of our energy
where we're not just tuned out here but
we have this
inner connection that we're starting the
day with and so it may feel restless at
first it was excruciatingly
difficult for me to sit in meditation
when i started over 12 years ago
but now that i have been meditating for
a while it continues to get deeper um
and deeper and deeper so anyone that's
like well you know what's the best thing
to do to get started i say you know do
the meditation every morning
if you don't have seven minutes i mean
i'm sorry but you gotta adjust your life
right so the practical enlightenment
meditations are inspired by the kriya
yoga that yo that yogananda brought from
the west and so there's three parts that
i find in his you know in this work
teaches us is really important the first
is some kind of physical movement just
to settle the body remember the end goal
of is not these asanas out of 196 sutras
only three mentioned poses this is not
the end goal stir asuka
it's to create steadiness and
comfortability so we can sit
and the second part is some breath work
for getting in and some of the breath
work you hear about today danica is like
violent and like really like fast that's
for something else you know yogananda
and yoga teaches us very clearly when we
are working to interiorize our energy
your breath should actually get slower
and slower and then the third part
is is merging your um limited ego with
the i am consciousness because the i am
remember i said before the i am that i
am this is the this is the consciousness
of the true self so then we create an
intention and work it around the i am so
um every week i put out free meditations
on the seluna app and on my website too
if anyone um wants to check them out but
that to me is the fundamental practice
and then we go through there's exercises
for introspection um there's amazing
practice if you're trying to call
something in the abundance chapter as
well this is something i recommend doing
three minutes a day at least where we
are self-generating um this feeling of
fullness because if we're moving around
let me say oh i want this i want to have
a nice apartment i want to have a nice
boyfriend whatever it is but if we're
moving around in the world in this lac
energy
it doesn't matter what we're saying
we're not living it so this is more you
know back to the underlying energy
matrix which is um recognizing that
everything is energy and we are dynamic
energy at our core we know the blood's
flowing the mitochondria is you know
working all this stuff is happening so
we want to work with that energy versus
just these empty words and how we
self-generate how we bring that energy
into every cell of the body yeah feeling
i
you know speaking of meditations and um
you know the power of them which you
know is such a reminder how
you know just to speak to at least like
what are the things that get you into
practice and talk about meditation and
you know i think also if i can add to
that just from my own opinion is like
having a designated place for it yeah
having like a a spot that you can go
where you know you'll be on your own
because let's say for example um here at
my house like my meditation area and
everything that i do like red light and
different things it's in my bedroom and
so when i'm here by myself i do them all
in the morning but when my boyfriend is
here i'm like i like if he's still in
bed i don't wanna or if he's up and i'm
not i might as well get get out there to
the kitchen or something like that and
it's like if i ever i'm realizing that
like someday cohabitating together is
like okay this this space needs to be in
a separate room where i can go to and do
these practices so that's my my own
add-on from my own um practices but
very practical yeah um
but that's why in my book they came out
years ago there's a whole chapter on a
woman cave a woman yes i remember that
just like being able to create your own
space that feels really good it's your
favorite chair and your favorite pillow
it's your favorite pictures it's your
favorite things and it just everything
in the space feels good and it's a
designated space so
one of my
lifelong goals that i had um was to go
to egypt and
so
i was with joe dispenza doing a little
retreat a little one day retreat and at
the end of it he taught us this practice
this meditation practice where you think
of what it is that you want
and you identify
a handful of reasons why and then
another handful of elevated emotions
that you would feel having accomplished
it or attained it done it
and um and so then at the end of the
meditation you access that and go into
those feelings and you and you you know
why you want to do it and then you
embody when your whole body like how it
would feel and so i was visualizing
myself in egypt and i was visually
visualizing the gratitude i have the aw
i would have and just like
seeing it and just feeling my whole body
full of energy and just joy and pride to
have like
made it there finally and and so anyway
i went through this practice and like
two hours later at dinner a girl taps me
on the shoulder and says hey i heard
you're interested in going to egypt and
i was like oh what and she said i was
like did i did you see what i wrote and
she said no but a girl said that you
were talking about egypt at some point
and so i was like yeah she goes well
there's a trip in february if you want
to go and this was
this was like october almost november of
2020 and then i went in february of 2021
and so
uh so anyway that's just you know the
power of embodying these feelings of
what you want and you know really going
really really getting into the feeling
of things i think is so powerful in
meditations
it is and also
one thing that um i forgot to mention
before we were talking about the
difference between constriction your
body will tell you when something feels
right or doesn't feel wrong
or right or wrong and then also this
feeling of um expansion right so
meditation true meditation and these
practices are experiential so
we can't really um there's two parts of
yoga there's the wisdom there's like the
sankia philosophy which is really
understanding the union with the true
self and we see it we read it but then
we live it through our meditations right
like we want it to really be um
it's just beyond the thought it's beyond
thinking it's this experience of that
union so
by nature what we're what we're looking
to create is union and expansion and so
what we want to do and the more we do
this we start to tune into what some
people call the way of things some
people call it the will of god
and i think there's a lot of manifesting
stuff out there that's kind of like
anything everything like create you know
do whatever you want to do
and you know manifest it and to an
extent that that is true because we do
have free will but i would say taking it
a step further is when we are in this
union we are not just isolated beings
right and we talk about this in the
warrior chapter we are
part of this collective there is this
oneness we're all part of source so we
start to feel
not just expansive within ourselves but
we start to feel more connected to
everything and everyone else so that
means that when we start to tune in it
means that the things that we work to
manifest and things that we work to
create it becomes more powerful when we
include the good of others as well so it
could be you know not just as literals
like him when a volunteer but it's like
you know what um we can journal about
this after we meditate you know what
project what does that does the planet
need right now like where can i put my
energy in how can i serve this or if
you're in a job let's see in an office
or at starbucks or whatever it is how
can i show up in my fullest energy to
give the most love today what's my
frequency what's my vibration so the
more we go along this path one of the
signs that we are starting to really
um progress
is that we have more expansion
in ourselves in our feelings and in our
in our goals like just life starts to
feel more we're not isolated anymore
we're not just so hyper fixated on
ourself again the ego it just starts to
feel
so much more meaningful and fulfilling
and then we feel like we stepped into
that flow we're not just doing you know
some idea even though it doesn't really
go along with the energy of what's
around
we're working with manifesting in the
you know the dao calls this too um the
dao day chain which i'm also a big fan
of lao tzu it just talks about this flow
of the way of things
um so that's a part of this work as well
yeah it's interesting i think about
how so much of the work is inward and
it's about you know looking at yourself
first and again how you treat yourself
is how you treat others most of the time
so whether it's forgiveness or love or
like my great lesson that i learned
i guess was last year still um only for
a little bit longer but last year
learning the learning the lesson of you
know i had been waiting so long through
relationships to have someone choose me
and i realized that the lesson was i was
supposed to be choosing myself yeah
that's probably why i had such a hard
time
you know towards the end of the
relationship even thinking to myself i
was like if i could do anything today
for myself what would i do and i'm like
oh i don't know i better write it down
can i come up with three things that i
would do for myself today like
you know i'm like that should have been
a pretty big red flag that i wasn't
choosing myself but um but i just hear
about how it's
how that in the self and even like
triggers it's like triggers or teachers
i mean i was just talking to my yes
talking to my therapist yesterday and
it's like you know something happens and
it's like like you said when you learn
that lesson that correlation between
childhood and you go okay when someone
is for me it's like if someone's like
lazy then i think to myself oh well what
does that mean and instead of you know
getting them to do more it's like okay
this is my issue i'm judging them and
i'm like oh that's because when i was a
kid i was never allowed to sleep in dad
would call it 8 am i would get in
trouble if i didn't have the cooler pack
to go to the race track like nothing was
ever like able to just be like i was
never able to be a kid
and um and i'm saying that and my
parents are wonderful and i love my
parents very much we have a great
relationship but it doesn't mean that
as
that all parents aren't going to give
their child some kind of dilemma some
kind of thing to deal with later whether
it's too much or too little love we're
all you know every parent's going to
give their kids something yeah and we
all have that childhood stuff don't we
yeah exactly but it's like not trying to
fix it on the outside but then of course
when you flip it and you think about
like purpose and you think about what
you do
it's like it's much more in service it's
like how you can help and so um but you
have to find that from the inside you
know as and so and from the true self as
opposed to the ego and you know thinking
about money or thinking about uh you
know
status or something like that and so you
know but true happiness is knowing
yourself but then of course being in
service it's like interesting because
there's the the like true joy and i feel
like we're all we're all meant to be in
community and i don't care who you
listen to you listen to any doctor or
scientist or spiritual person and
they'll all tell you that like it's
community it's to be together it's it's
it's a fundamental core trait of being a
human being and and finding your purpose
is
a core is of a core essence of what we
need to figure out
yeah i would say the you know the reason
um service again is so is so powerful
because it's part of this energy of
expansion so the more we just think
small and we think about our needs it
keeps us in the ego it keeps us in that
very limited isolated energy which does
stagnate and never will give us the
fulfillment that we want i don't care
how much money you have or how much
you've accomplished if you're not
including the good of others then you do
remain contained
um and also you know you're saying about
the childhood stuff
the reason it's so important to do these
practices to get into the body to get
into the breath to get into all these
yogic teachings which are very specific
about how to work with the spine how to
work with um all you know all this
amazing um stuff is because the ego
keeps us in um these categories right
wrong black white this is good this is
bad it's constantly judging it's
constantly looking out and putting
things in boxes
and really um that is
very arduous it sucks up a lot of energy
think about how much you know energy is
sucked up in judgment including judgment
especially judgment of the self so it's
like always there's these like little
voices and like the pickiness
so that's why
the the the solution to the problem is
not found where the problem is it's not
found in like trying to make the ego
shinier and like better makeup or like
maybe i'm gonna do more it comes from
this expansive stable place of beingness
and the power of the beingness gets
expanded into
you know what can i do what's inspired
action that's yoked that's in union with
the true self and that will include by
its definition ways in which it can
support and help other people um because
that is what expansion is otherwise you
know
it's also when we start to do this work
like i said you start to realize you
don't need that much from the outside
you become more autonomous i'm not
trying to get all this stuff from other
people i give it to myself so then it's
like i'm good right i'm i'm good so in
my time here on earth like what am i
gonna do i'm gonna
do things that are going to help others
because i'm already good i'm whole i'm
stable i'm complete so this is like the
highest and best use of my time and i
want people to also feel more love and
more you know compassion and to feel
this peace
you also say in the book that love is an
action yes and i think that's
like that hit me i was like
okay because
have you ever seen the movie contact
with um matthew mcconaughey and jodie
foster oh man like a long time about
it's about going to space so it's like
you know it's getting a signal from
outer space and decoding it and building
this yeah device and this huge device
and matthew mcconaughey plays the the
he's a he's really the religious side
the spiritual religious side of things
and and jody foster's the scientific you
know mind
and she needs to be able to prove things
and so
it's kind of this
this battle between the two and it's
like whoever ends up going to space ends
up being someone that's actually that
kind of has religion involved in their
life and she just can't buy into
religion because it can't be proven and
so he says to her he goes
her dad died when when she was young in
the movie and he says to her
did you love your dad and she goes of
course
and he said prove it
and i was like oh my god yeah that's
right like you can't prove it and when
so when i read that when love is an
action i went that's it like you don't
prove like you don't prove out an action
you just do it it just is
that's right so one of the things um
that i think is powerful to get across
like if anybody's listening to this and
they're like i do want a relationship or
i do want more love i do want whatever
more fulfilling friendships whatever it
is
the way that we approach it is again
this like place of lack like oh i gotta
get on more dating apps i gotta spend
more time i gotta you know i just gotta
be i have to be doing more
and it's really the ego
this getting this is lack right so the
difference is when we turn it on
ourselves and love as an action means
today how can i live love even as i wake
up in the first five minutes i can send
a text to someone and tell them i love
them i can be extra kind to the barista
where i get coffee i can hug my pet or
like the first you know living thing i
see i you know i give it so much love we
start to live in the fullness and
abundance of love we become the source
of love because we are tuned into the
source of love so now that becomes so
attractive people are drawn to you
because instead of you trying to get it
which is like oh my god it's like a
leech a leech energy it's it's people
are drawn to you there's a there's a
certain magnetism to it
and again um there is um dr david
hawkins had a scale for measuring some
of the frequencies of emotions oh yeah
that i reference in the book and also a
neuroscientist that i recently had on my
podcast was talking about how mind isn't
just in the brain it's in it's in the
cells of the body it's also this
gravitational field outside so more and
more science shows that there is you
know it's not this woo hoo
like
like
the secret got a really bad rap a few
years ago because it was just like oh
just imagine something and it comes it
got you know some people it got a little
bit oversimplified but there is a truth
to everything is energy everything is
kinetic pulsating it's not just empty
space but it is energetic
so
whether it's abundance that we're trying
to create or more love we're trying to
track in it really does start with
tuning in to that inner state and what
frequency we are showing up into each
moment with knowing again that that
repeated frequency is starting to create
something in the outside world
and this is something i get into more
detail about in the uh magnetism chapter
and if you're there yet danica but when
i
i write how i i met deepak um chopra
because he was like a you know a
childhood hero of mine i read a lot of
his books from when i was a teenager on
and so to go from that into actually
writing a book with him was this you
know this practice practice of really
tuning into
magnetism which is something i think we
can all develop and that's the practical
nature of this book and the teachings
it's not you know oh i hope this happens
like i really love these concepts it's
no yogic science there is a science into
that you know working with the spine
working with these energies you do it
day in and day out even if it's five
minutes ten minutes you know in the
morning night it does change your energy
and it does change your external life i
mean
you know i'm talking about abundance i
was you know not so long ago like
completely broke coming back from
backpacking i used to get three oranges
for lunch for a dollar because i read a
study that oranges kept you full the
longest
into
again just
we can't just you know fear is when we
think the world is just what we see with
our eyes you know where i am today
what's in the bank account versus
stepping into the flow of the trees true
self so i started to do that and now oh
the love soulmate hubby you know the
babies the land here where you've been
danica now we were able to just buy a
farm in hawaii so just creating without
it doesn't mean everything in my life is
perfect but it means there's just more
easefulness there's more harmony in each
moment so there's not this same like
pushing and anxiety that i used to
experience so much of
and i know that's possible for everybody
it doesn't have to be the same system of
the ego
what comes to mind when you talk about
that is i'm thinking about the story
about you know your mom passing and you
know
and and maybe you want to share that um
or something about it but the thing that
comes to mind is letting go and just how
powerful that is just in our because
there's going to be things that come up
right and um you know the less triggered
we are the better of course but they're
still going to be things that you just
have to let go of i have a saying my
saying this year has been oh well and
it's really powerful something happens
oh well oh
that is so important this this um this
concept that life doesn't have to be so
serious and this again let's talk about
control for a second which is the
antithesis of letting go which is a you
know what the ego tries to do it tries
to set things up so it's predictable so
it's safe for us because it's like i
want it to be this way exactly
so to you know if anyone's gonna watch
this or i'll explain it but you know
usually we're like holding on so tightly
to what we want letting go it's like you
open your hand and now look at the
receptivity look at the difference in
energy
so with my mom it was it was a
it was a wild roller coaster because we
were together christmas and i'm telling
you danica it was like normal like
everything was you know my son was like
eight months old i think at the time we
were just wrapping presents and laughing
and walking the beach and doing all this
stuff and then
you know and then it was like my dad
called me on february 7th i remember
because my birthday's on the six so you
want to call me my birthday the day
after he's like you know something's
wrong with mom she's tired
you know she's in bed and i flew back
right away and it was like me and her
alone i was holding her hand when the
doctor called and said we found cancer
and then you know went from like me in
doing mode
being like i know how to you know i know
how to take care of you i've worked with
other people with cancer as a wellness
person as well i know how to do the
nutrition and there's like running
around like no we can fix this people
have healed from cancer into you know i
think two or three weeks in they were
like look her body's just you know
swelling she's not absorbing anything
the protein you know maybe she has a few
years
and i was like a few years i was like i
don't want to lose
my mom in my 30s i was like this is not
gonna happen like no so then i was like
kept racing around but it was it was
unfolding it was starting to be obvious
that i couldn't control this so it went
from a few years
i think in like the next week he was
like you know she is less than two weeks
so is this ultimate like ripping the
veil away of like thinking you have any
sort of sort of control
and then it was down to that last night
i remember i said squeeze my hands if
you can still hear me and she squeezed
and so i looked at she was like for two
hours she looked at me with her black
eyes danica and i could tell her
everything you know love is everlasting
um you know i will love you forever
and then she was
not able to let go because i could tell
she was really worried about my dad so
this was the hardest thing i've ever
done you know i had to look at her and
say your mom it's okay
like you can go i will take care of
daddy like i will be here and i knew she
registered it because then her breath
got slower and slower and then
she let go and i had to let go and it
was this
you know sometimes we we cling because
we think it's like this is how it has to
be but when we let go it's like we're
letting go into that space we're letting
go into that expansion and from that
experience you know i just feel like oh
the love
you know that
it's not
i'm trying to get you to always be here
to support me it was letting go into i
know that love is eternal and
your soul needs to go somewhere else
this isn't about me
and whoa that changed my whole
perspective to love
danica and um was part of that whole
like unearthing period where i emerged
like so
so much more whole and um to what you
were saying like more relaxed
because it's like things can happen at
any time and it's like
who gives a [ __ ] about so much of the
planning like we're here right now you
know who are we being in this moment am
i in true self am i in expanse love or
am i not and if i'm not i want to
recognize that and keep coming back to
center you know faster and faster really
are these wounded humans we're acting
things out we don't want to you know um
not be compassionate with ourselves but
we want to start to wake up to
the love
the potential that's here in this moment
because
you know i think that's why we're here
right
thank you for sharing that wow i mean i
still get teared up i cried when i read
it
and then i
cried a little right now hearing you
tell this tell the story and
you know getting into the emotion of it
so thank you for for going there with
with us um
i mean it it really actually just
pivots right into the title of the book
doesn't it yeah i mean think about it
like
you know
you're more than you think you are and
i'm sure that you know you probably
feel that with your mom now i'm sure you
notice her in places oh yeah and i mean
feel her and um
you know
the quicker that we realize that we're
more than we think the quicker we can
practice stepping into more of it
exactly the more we realize that we're
not this shell but we have this
unlimited eternal part of us and we tune
into that for so many of our needs the
peace we're looking for the confidence
we're seeking the the soothingness the
love all of it
is here it's inside of us
so when we do this more and more and
this you know this desperate seeking
outside of ourselves starts to diminish
our energy grows our true power grows
and we're able to serve each other more
and connect and love and show up and
just beingness instead of all the you
know the judging and the way all the
ways in which we are competitive or tear
each other down
and so i just feel like oh my god danica
of all the things right this is needed
the most in the world today just gonna
say that i'm like we need this book
right now
and you know i was listening to a joe
rogan podcast with a couple of guys
talking about the state of the world and
algorithms and social
platforms and stuff and you're trying to
come up with a reason how to how to how
to move forward what to do next and
um
you know it's
it's a it's a it's a really interesting
world out there yeah really the only
thing that they kind of touched on that
made any kind of sense other than joe
talking about psychedelics was um was uh
getting to the south like we have to
change like you can't expect someone
else to change you can't you know in the
times that will you can't expect the
government to change you can't accept
social
you know giant companies and
institutions to change you can't expect
that those things to change you can't
expect if you can't even expect your
partner to change like how do you
seriously ever expect anything else
that's any bigger than that uh to change
and that the only way that things really
change is when you yourself change
exactly it's all internal and then your
outer world at least in relation to you
starts to change and the more of us
change there is a
movement that starts to take place but
real quick about social media i mean do
you remember when all that stuff came
out a few weeks ago or a few months ago
now the whistleblower stuff all the
studies they knew how horrible it was
for women especially in mental health so
it's like one of the things you know so
many people write into to me and you
know my podcast and stuff about feeling
bad about being on social media and
there's a there's a reality to that if
we're not anchored in here we're going
to go on there we're going to get
triggered left and right because we're
an ego so i highly suggest
batching when you're on there only
certain times i certainly do not want to
be on there before i meditate and
establish myself i don't want to be in
there in the morning because i'm you
know
you know just focused here so i think
it's important that we put in these
systems so we start to again work with
our own energy we just don't give our
power away alerts coming in all day long
always throwing us off always pulling us
off center so create specific times when
you want to be on social media follow
only people that feel really positive to
you that you feel good about put out put
out posts put out things that you know
feel
connect with you and your truth and you
feel really good about putting out um so
to me that's the way that i think is you
know for me the ways that i try to make
social media positive more positive
there's a way to look at anything
as it's kind of like the the topic of
duality and oneness it's like
interesting because
if you'd asked me a few years back what
i thought the point of this existence
was i would say to experience duality
like to experience all that being human
ha offers
but what i realized in
the
dualistic nature of life the good and
the bad
is that the more good and the more the
more actually unfortunately it ended up
being the more bad i felt the more i
realized without without getting a good
the more easy i was able to access joy
and happiness in simple moments
and so
by pushing by getting further into the
into the sadness or into into
into into you know
desperate emotions and
and and the bad i felt the good
automatically and in that moment like in
those moments over enough of them
happened last year i realized that
that they're part of the same hole it
was almost like i was bumping my like
emotional intelligence a little wider
and wider
um by feeling even just one emotion
there was almost a
a a bounce to the other side
and this
is our true nature
exactly the ego thinks like good bad i
don't want to feel this so i'm going to
distract i'm going to eat a bunch of
cookies i'm going to do whatever i can
to not feel this
sadness or this anger whatever it is
like think about all the ways in which
we try to put those parts of us away we
we disown we keep the shadow alive
actually with more of that
abandonment versus just letting
everything come up and starting to find
more neutrality and really um
neuroscience shows that these um like
it's biochemical reactions when we feel
really strong emotion so if we don't
attach the narrative if we don't have
the story to it it usually dissipates
and again 90 seconds so we want to get
to this point where again pratyahara
it's all our energy isn't going out here
so we get caught up in the drama of life
we follow this little reaction and
suddenly we get in a fight with our
spouse or a boyfriend or a friend and
cleaning up the message just like taking
us away from our power right so
pratyahara is like okay all this stuff's
out here i sense it i see it i witness
it more and more versus getting drawn in
and really i'm just pulling it in here
i'm staying in here i'm showing up here
this is how i can serve the most i know
my truth i need less and less from the
outside and here's where i create from
and this is where our best stuff comes
forward
that's what you did with this
[Music]
book love you
thank you thank you so much
you're honestly just a wonderful human
like sharing your space when i came last
year and just you know introducing me to
friends and sitting in circle and
you know just spending time you come
back
i i plan on it i plan on it
yeah definitely can't wait to see so
many good people in california oh
amazing yeah and then come over and one
day you'll have to come over to hawaii
too danica i think a better idea i might
like hawaii a little better than
california oh my god for some reasons
not others uncle oh yeah talk about just
nature and the power and um
yeah it's you'll totally vibe oh well
thank you so much thanks everybody for
listening to the pretty intense podcast
today i hope you enjoyed it if you like
what you heard today and you want to
hear more please click on the subscribe
button